sorry my microphone is off i'm sorry
judy i got it
so
uh
all right
i hope lunch went okay all right good
all right your next witness
your honor we call mr john c depp all
right
if it's dancer
so
okay all right yes ma'am
good afternoon mr depp
good afternoon
can you please tell the jury why you're
here today
um
yes
um
about six years ago
um
misheard
made
some
quite heinous and um
disturbing
brought these disturbing criminal um
acts
um
against
uh me that uh
that were not based in
any species of truth
um
it was a it was a complete shock
uh
that it would
it it just didn't need to go
in that direction
um
as
nothing nothing of the kind that ever
happened
though
the relationship
um
there were
um
arguments
and
um
things of that nature
but never
did i myself
reach the point of
striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
in my life
and so i
at the time
because the
news of this
her
accusations had
sort of permeated the industry and then
made its way through
media and social media became quite a
global um
um
let's say quote-unquote fact if you will
and
since i knew that there was no truth to
it whatsoever
i felt it my responsibility to
to stand up
not only for myself
in that instance but stand up for my
children
who at the time were
uh
14 and 16.
and so they were in
high school and uh
i i
i thought it was diabolical that my
children would have to go to
um
school and
have their friends or
people in the school
approach them with
the infamous
people magazine cover with
misheard with a
a dark bruise on her face
um
and then it just
kept
um
the
it kept multiplying it
it just kept getting bigger and bigger
so it was my responsibility i felt
to not only
attempt to clear
my name
um
for the sake of
for many reasons but
i wanted to clear
uh my children of of this hard thing
that they
were having to read about their father
that was which was untrue
and also after many years of being in
this
industry
um but
at the time it was probably
i'd probably been in the industry 30
plus years 35 years
never have had any
problems anything like that
and i'd met many people
over the years many many of the people
and had had
the opportunity to talk to those people
and to
um
even
give advice to these people
and i'm
i'm not
my goal is the truth
my goal is the truth
because
it
it killed me that
people that i had spoken with that i had
met with over the years who i
who maybe were in a
not such a great position and they
needed advice
and i gave them
the best advice i could
um
all i could think of was that those
people
would would
think that i um
was a fraud and that i had lied to them
and
so i had to wait
for my opportunity to
address the charges
which were
criminal charges
um
and and then they just weren't um true
so i i felt
the responsibility of clearing the
record
as
the only
the only way that i could get that i
could
get to the point where i could speak
um has
really
taken
this full six years
and it's been six years of
trying
times it's very
strange when
one day your
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds your
quasimodo
and um i
i
i didn't
deserve that nor did my
children nor did the people who have
believed in me for
all these years i i didn't want anybody
any of those people to
believe that i had
done them wrong or lied to them or that
i was a fraud
i i i'm
i pride myself on honesty i pride
myself on
truth truth is the only thing i'm
interested in
other
lies will get you nowhere but um
lies build upon lies and build upon lies
it's too much to cover i i
i'm obsessed with the truth and um so
today is my
actually my the first uh opportunity
that i've been able to
speak about this
um case
for the first time
mr depp how do you feel about the
intimate details of your life being
aired in this process
um
as a father
um
raising kids
you know when they were very very little
um it was important to me
very important to me
to
[Music]
to try to
shield my children as much as possible
from
um
looking at their father
uh or their or their mom for that matter
uh
as uh
novelties
i i didn't want my children to
experience
um hordes of paparazzis
um
so i was always a very private
person
so for me to
come up here and stand before you or sit
before you
all
and
spill
the truth
um
is quite exposing
and um
it's unfortunate that it's not only
exposing
for myself it's exposing for my
family it's exposing for misheard it's
exposing for
it's um
it never had to go
in this direction
and so i
i can't say that i'm embarrassed because
i know that i'm doing the right thing
now mr depp i'd like to turn a bit to
your upbringing we heard a bit from your
sister christy last week but can you
please tell the jury in your own words
about your your childhood upbringing
um
i had a very
interesting
childhood
one that i thought was normal until a
certain age
my mother um
i was born in kentucky
and um
then we moved
in which we moved around quite a lot um
when i was a kid
so you were always
just my mom had this
her feet were on fire and she had to
move you know so we moved constantly
so you were always the new kid and
that wasn't ever particularly pleasant
then we moved to florida
south florida when i was about seven or
eight
um
and again moved several several times
but um my mother was
quite unpredictable
she was very unpredictable
she was a
she had the ability to be
as as cruel as anyone can be
um
with all of us that is to say my sister
christy and my
my brother danny and my sister debbie
and
also my father
so
um
essentially
she was
she could become quite violent
and she was quite violent
and she was quite cruel and she
and
though
there was physical
abuse certainly
um which could be in the form of uh
an ashtray being flung at you
you know it hit you in the head or
you'd get beat with a high-heeled shoe
or a telephone or whatever's handy
um
so
in our house
there was no
we were never exposed to any
type of
safety
or security
the the
the only thing that one could do
really
um was to try to stay out of the line of
fire
you um
i started to
be able to observe
and
i could see i could start to see when
she was about to
head into a uh
wouldn't
head into a situation where she was
going to get riled up and somebody was
going to get it
and
generally
uh
it was me
mr depp you mentioned that your mother
could be cruel how could she be cruel
um
the various categories i suppose are
there are there's there's physical
violence of course there's physical
abuse
um
to which she was um
that was a constant
that was just a constant you
know we were all somewhat shell-shocked
you know even if she just walked past
you you
you'd sort of shield yourself because
you didn't know what was gonna happen
excuse me
and um
so there was there was the physical
abuse which was was
a constant
um
there was
quite a lot of verbal abuse there was
quite a lot of name calling and
um
bullying
you know
making fun of making fun of
whatever
defect you know
one might have you know my brother wore
glasses
so of course he was
four eyes
and he had his teeth were messed up in
the front so he was bucked to through as
well and
um
my sister christy
which this is such a
a hideous psychological play
uh
my my my father's
parents were quite
refined my mother comes from eastern
kentucky which is
is
where you grow up in
shacks and holla and hollers you know
and
my my mother
despised uh my father's parents
and my grandmother's name was violet
and
every now and again you would hear my
mother just scream across the house
come here violent get into your violet
and
christy my sister knew very well
that that was a deep
a deep cut
psychologically emotionally
but
we had to take it i mean
you just had to take the pain
um
i i was born
with a very strange is a very rare
uh
thing
in my
eye as the
the
the back of the
lens is spherical
uh normally um is spherical is when this
eye isn't normal
this eye i was born
with a more conical
lens so
my
brain never learned to see out of my
left eye
and they noticed
when i was about
three four five
three four
that i had a lazy eye
a wandering eye and um
she would call me and she would call me
kakai
one eye
um
any anything
anything she could get to to uh
demean humiliate
um
uh i even had to wear um
i had to wear an eye patch on my good
eye
uh to strengthen my
my bad eye so that it
would cease to wander it was a must it
was exercising the muscles of the eye
though the brain had never learned to
see so i still
my
vision and my left eye is
i'm legally blind in my left eye
but um
so yeah the the
the verbal abuse the psychological abuse
was uh
was almost worse than the the
the the beatings
because the beatings were just physical
pain
and the physical pain
you learn to deal with you learn to
accept it he learned to
deal with it
but the
psychological and emotional abuse
that's what
that's what kind of tore us up i think
what about your father what was he like
my father my father was a very
kind man in fact my father's still alive
he's
he's a very kind man
he's a very quiet man
in fact he's
very shy
[Music]
not a confrontational
person in any way
and when
betty sue my mother
um
would go off
on on on a tangent
toward my my father
um
and and and of course in front of the
kids it was no matter to her
uh
he would
he would um
he amazingly remained very very stoic
and uh
never
as she was
rationing him with
horrible
things
he stood there and just
looked at her
while she delivered the pain
and he swallowed it he took it
there was never
one moment
never a moment when my father
lost control
and attacked my mother or hit my mother
or even said
he even said a bad thing to my mother
what what i the things that i witnessed
were
there were a couple of times when
it got too far
that i i would see his i could see his
eyes welling up
as he was staring at her saying nothing
um and then the most that he would do is
he would
he would he would punch
a wall
i i once saw him punch a wall and
shatter his hand because it wasn't it
wasn't drywall it was
um
proper concrete and
steel wire and rebar and
things of that nature and
um but still never never touched her
never um
argued with her
he uh
he he remained a gentleman and to me as
a five-year-old boy
i kept thinking to myself
i kept wondering why
why does he take it
how does he
how does he take this
and and and and why doesn't he leave her
um
but he didn't you know
he was able to
maintain
his calm and his composure
he was able to maintain
uh his relationship with his children
um
he was he was he was a good man
he is a good man
you mentioned that you saw your father
punch a wall how many times did you
witness that
i mean
out of
out of
i couldn't count the amount of fights
that they had but i i i know that i
i've seen my father strike
a wall um
two
or three times tops
once
when he broke his hand
um
but it
two
two three times at tops you know
was your father ever abusive to you or
any of your siblings
no my father was never
my father was
not an abusive man
at the same time my father was also
to some degree at the mercy of betty
uh
sue
if he
argued with what she
wanted
done
that would just turn into
another um
barrage of of hatred uh towards him
so i can remember
my father coming home from work and
maybe i'd
i'd
gotten a bad report card or maybe i'd
gotten in trouble at school or
something like that
and my father would arrive home from
work and the first thing she would say
was john
take take him out there
he gets the belt give him the belt
and he wanted to know what it was about
so he'd take me out to the garage
and
i'll never forget the uh this
white
thick leather
1970s era
thick leather white belt that he would
um
take off and and um
and then he would commence to
inflict the punishment
on on me
but interestingly there was there was
one time
when my father
i i kept telling him i i didn't do this
it was another incident i kept swearing
to him that i i did not do what betty
sue my mom had said
that i'd done
but
he went through with the punishment
anyway
and then
not long after he found out that
i had been telling the truth
and that i hadn't done
what i
what my mom had said that i'd done
um
and he he came to me and uh apologized
to me
for um
for having gone through with the weapon
you know the belt
and um
i have to say
my mom never did that
she couldn't
she knew what she knew she was raised
how she was raised
and um
i had no power to change what was inside
of her
you know
how did your parents relationship
ultimately come to an end to your
understanding
um
when my father left i i didn't realize
that he
had left he left her
i was 15 i had already
left school
and i was a musician i was playing in
clubs and such
and
he left for work one morning just like
every day
and
was packing his car
and then he left
and then hours later
my mom betty sue came home from work it
was about 3 30 in the afternoon
and she walked in the door
and stopped
and and just looked around like she
felt something
and she just i said what's wrong she
said your daddy's gone
i said well yeah i seen him leave for
work this morning he said no no no no
he's gone he's gone
and she ran into the uh
into their bedroom
and into their closet and i followed her
and i
she opened the door
and there was one yeah his side his rack
of
clothing and all his belongings were
gone
and she was quite
upset
and i took her car and drove to my
father's work
and i
sat down in front of him at 15 and i
said listen
seems as though somebody stole all your
clothes out of the closet
and um
and he said uh he said yeah
yeah he said uh i'm done
i can't
i can't do it anymore i can't i can't
live it anymore
you're the man you're the man now
and uh
those words
didn't didn't quite sit well with me i i
didn't feel like i was ready to hear
those words
but
that's what i got um
then my mom
got very went into a very very dark uh
place a very deep dark depression as you
can imagine
and um
and uh
she
one afternoon i
woke up i i'd fallen asleep
and
i woke up and walked out into the
living room
and i saw my my mother
um
like
very feebly
um
and
like almost it was like a
slow motion
crawl
if i could stand up i could show you
just
the
what i saw
demand you know
thank you
um
i saw
i saw
my mother
you know in that in that mode
so instantly
i knew that something was dreadfully
wrong
and um
there's drool coming out of her mouth
and
as i was about to run and call
the front door busted open and
my uncle
and
two paramedics came in
and um
on the gurney
and whisked her out of the house
to get her to the hospital to um to pump
her stomach and she'd uh she had
swallowed a multitude of of pills
to to
to try to take herself out to
try to commit suicide
and uh
when she got out of the hospital
she was a small
firecracker of a woman she was about
five foot two
but when she got out of the hospital the
depression was so
deep
she she was down to like
she lived on the couch and she
weighed about 70 pounds
and
that
all that imagery
spun into my head
at that time that
i thought that was a very
in my head at the time i thought that
that was a cowardly way
for my father to have left
and i i was uh
deeply upset by that
um
until
my father and i had a conversation
years later
where
i asked him
what really
happened what how did it happen
when i was older
and he told me the story
runner may we approach
um
mr duff how did you feel about your
father when he left
i would
i was
i was
i was very disappointed in him because i
started to believe that his
exit was was
sneaky cowardly
he didn't when he said goodbye to me
when he left for work that morning he
said goodbye you know goodbye bob and i
went
see you later pop that was it
until
um i learned the truth
from uh from him
and without getting into what your
father told you
why is
how has your
impression of your father changed now
objection relevance
your honor this is just an understanding
of his perception of his family
i'll sustain the objection next question
mr deb what have you learned from
your experience in your childhood
and observing your father in your
childhood
i learned that i was
wrong about my first impressions of his
his exit from the family
um very wrong
and um
i'll tell you
i'll tell you one thing
that i learned
that was that was uh
one of the best lessons i believe i've
ever learned in my life ever could learn
in your life in my life
was um
based on my experiences as a child
and
what i'd seen and experienced i
knew exactly
how to raise children
um when
when uh
when
my girl vanessa got pregnant
um
i knew exactly how to raise children
which was to do the opposite of what
they did of what betty sue did
never raise your voice in front of the
children never
screaming out the word no to them
i never wanted to tell my kids no i i
wanted to tell them that
i wanted to show them that there were
options you don't have to stick the coat
hanger in the electrical socket
you know
saying no
is an abrupt thing
but to talk to them and say
if you understand the repercussions of
something then you won't go there so
maybe think about
this as opposed to this
give this some thought you know
but that will clearly
um
that could kill you
so
i i would ease them away from
um
things of that nature with a more more
of a
more of a conversation as opposed to a a
a
you know a flat out don't you ever do
that again and threats and things of
that nature i did not raise my children
that
way nor nor did vanessa we and we never
raised our voices in front of our
children ever
how do you think your experiences with
your parents in your childhood affected
your approach to your relationship with
miss heard
i'm sorry
one more time
how did your experiences observing your
parents as a child
affect your approach to your
relationship with miss heard
well
in the beginning of my relationship with
miss herod
um there was
from what i
recall and what i remember she was
she was um
it was as if she were it was she was too
good to be true
um
she was
attentive she was
loving um
she was smart she was
kind she was funny she
was understanding she
um
and we we had many things in common
certain
blues music and
well music
literature things of that nature so
for that year
or year and a half it was uh
it was amazing um there were a couple of
things that
i don't know stuck in my head that i
noticed that i thought
might be a little bit of a
dilemma at some point
for example for example
if i if i
i was worked quite a lot
and when i would
come home from work
um
i would i would
come in the house or the hotel
and
she would sit me down on the couch
and give me a glass of wine
and
take my boots off
set them to the side and
i've never experienced anything like
that in in my life i i just never
thought
that was
i just never experienced that before
and it became a regular thing
um
that she did
this kind of routine
and i remember one night i came home
from work and
i think she was on the phone or
something and
her busy she was doing something and
um
so i sat down on the couch and i took my
boots off
and um
suddenly
miss her approached
with this
look on her face that she and she just
said what did you just do
what did you do
i said what do you mean
you took your boots off
i said
i said yeah yes i did you you you were
busy you know no no no that's my job
that's what i do
you don't do that i do that
okay
all right then
and then she said let me get you a glass
of wine she brought me the glass of wine
but i did take pause of course
the fact that she was
visibly
shaken or upset
that i had
i had broken her
rules of routine
i thought that strange and then
once that once you notice something like
that
then you start to notice other little
tidbits and things that come out
and then
and then
within a
year year and a half
she
had become this
another person
almost mr deb we're going to talk about
miss heart in a couple minutes but i'd
like to first talk about
um your career in hollywood and so could
you please tell the jury how you ended
up acting in the first place um
i ended up acting by accident
i uh
was a musician and i moved out to los
angeles with my
band
when i was
20 years old
and then there were
a couple of
things that happened
in the back where the band split up and
i remember i was filling out job
applications and then nick
with a friend of mine and who happens to
be
he was an actor
uh less known than than he is now
nicholas cage um and i was filling out
job applications at any video stores
clothing stores anything and just to
be able to pay the rent and
um
nick cage said uh you know
why don't you meet my agent you know uh
because i
i think you're an actor i think you
could be an actor
and i said look i'll meet anybody you
know i'll do anything at this point
and so he sent me to his
his agent eileen feldman
and i met with her
[Music]
um
she sent me to read for a
casting director named annette benson
who was casting a film called the
nightmare on elm street
and
they brought me back to read for the
director
wes craven
and
[Music]
i read for wes
uh craven and
somehow got the job but i mean i was by
no means
an actor
i didn't have any desire to be an actor
i was a musician
but
the fact that these
people were going to pay me
what i
found to be a ludicrous sum of money
which was
it was kind of the sag minimum
uh it was twelve hundred and eighty four
dollars
a week
which i mean you know i'd never
seen that kind of dough
before in my life
um
and so
i i suddenly
you know then i did some other couple of
dumb movies because i i i
still in my mind i was
a musician and this was just a way to
pay the rent pay the bills live
um then suddenly i found myself
on that road i had been placed on that
road
as a
as an actor and then i
one thing led to another from film to
film and then i
was cast in a tv series called 21 jump
street
when i was 22
i believe
mr deb between the time that you
were cast in nightmare on elm street and
you
were cast in 21 drums jump street how
did you enjoy acting during that time
it was foreign to me
it was foreign to me but i i didn't
i didn't have any great
ambition
to be an actor i
i'm
a uh
naturally normally
i'm
i've always been quite a shy person i've
always been quite
introverted
and
so
there was a very strange
metamorphosis from
being one of four
that is to say
one
of four in a band where you have this
fraternity or this brotherhood
um
and you're out there
fighting the world together to try to
get that record deal or whatever you're
looking for
and uh
when the
when i got on the series
and my life started to change in various
ways that is to say that people started
to
you know you go into a restaurant
you'd see people whispering and pointing
and
all that i was uh
i was very uncomfortable with it i was
very uncomfortable with it and i didn't
like it
um
just just because it
i
i never wanted to be the lead singer and
the guy out front and
we'll get all the attention and i i
didn't so
suddenly i was on my own and i was uh
having to deal with this uh
this this this newfound sort of
notoriety
and it was it was odd it was very odd
and it was
yeah it was a very uncomfortable thing i
mean i don't think it's anything that
one can get used to i don't i i wouldn't
i'm not i'm still not used to it now and
i which
i'm actually glad that i'm not used to
it
because if i were i don't think i'd be
the same person
that i am
mr depp did there come a time when you
became passionate about acting
once i realized that i that that's the
road that i was
on
and
that any attempt at going back to music
would
would be a
um
not
it would have been
i hated the idea that
since the television series had
come out and i had been exposed as this
this this character or this actor uh
um i had to realize in in my own mind
and heart that there was no going back
to music because i i didn't want to
you know i didn't want to
i didn't want to
use
whatever
amount of success that i had
attained from the tv series and
that sort of thing
i didn't want to use that
to
influence
um
you know some career in music i i
had far too much respect for
uh music
um than to just to become what they
wanted me to become which was a you know
teen idol or a teeny you know that
that's that sort of thing
i um i fought that with
with everything in my being
so
once i realized that music was no longer
an option
then
i began to study
um
at various places in the loft studio
which is now long gone
um in in los angeles i
studied with
some other teachers uh saunders c cat um
[Music]
i read
all the books that you could read and
all that was great
but um you realize that
the only way to
the only way to
learn or the only way to learn how to
is not act necessarily
the only
way to learn how to react
and behave
because it's just behavior and its
reaction
um
was to do it
you
it's on the job training it's trial by
fire
so um
i did my best to
to work up work my work up my own
approach towards the towards
the character and such
and what were a couple of the first few
projects that you worked on where you
were really able to implement that
approach
i would say
i i i would say that the
first
film that i had done
that i really took um
where i really felt okay
i've done the work i i i
know what i need to do
um
i would say that was that without
where i considered myself an actor i
suppose was was was when um
oliver stone cast me in uh
platoon in
1986.
how did you come to be cast in pirates
of the caribbean
uh
well that's that's many years later but
uh
i
i had been um disney had offered me a
film
um
called
hidalgo
when it was about a man
his horse in the desert and stuff and i
i read the the screenplay
and i just didn't think it was for me
um but
i wanted to have a meeting with them
because
i at that point i had a um two-year-old
uh
yeah two to
two and a half-year-old daughter
and
or three
and and and
for three years i watched nothing but
animated
films
um
uh cartoons from texas avery to bugs
bunny to
um
that that was all i i watched with my
with my
little girl
and
i
received the screenplay for pirates
and
it was i
somehow in my mind i saw this
opportunity like a way to mesh
characters
like cart black cartoon characters for
example
wiley coyote gets a boulder dropped on
his head
and he's completely crushed but in the
cut to the next scene and he's just got
a little bandage on his head
so i i started thinking about the the
parameters
that are that were available to cartoon
characters
and
if they were available to cartoon
characters
and and and
nobody ever asked a question whether you
were 5 or 95 you didn't ask a question
oh wiley of course he's still alive
so i tried to
incorporate
these uh
these kind of ideas into the character
of captain jack sparrow
so that
so
so that
i could try to push those parameters
and
and and control the sort of suspension
of disbelief
to be able to control the
um characters
actions words movements
and put them in a place where
the things that he would do or say were
so
either ludicrous
or
mainly something that
also something
the cartoon characters can get away with
things we can't
captain jack sparrow can do things that
i could never do he could say things
that i could never say
so it was for me
a way to
stretch the parameters of of a character
and
and take take a risk
uh in doing that but
if it if it panned out
i
i
and i felt i was on a
pretty good mission
if it panned out i thought that it might
be a character
who would be accepted by
five-year-olds
and 45 year olds and
65 year olds and 85 year olds and
in the same way that bugs bunny is uh
you know
you mentioned that sorry you mentioned
that you received the script when was
that i'm sorry
when did you first receive the script
for pirates of the caribbean uh the the
first screenplay i i received was uh
2002 i believe yeah
2002. and what did you think of that
script when you received it
um i thought that it had all the
kind of hallmarks of a of a
of a disney film that is to say
a kind of a predict predictable
predictable three-act structure
um
with
um
with
and the character
of captain jack was
was more um
he was more like a swashbuckler type
that would kind of swing in
shirtless and
you know be the hero um
and i
i had quite different ideas about the
characters so i
incorporated
my
notes into character and
brought that character to life
um much to the chagrin of disney
initially
now when you say you made changes to the
character how did you do that
um just
you know in preparation you know
the same the very same way that i've
ever approached any character you you
you look for a back history you base it
on
um
you know it could be anything like
edward scissorhands for example was
i based on a
dog that i'd had and a
newborn babies
my sister had a couple of new babies and
i watched them you know
because i thought that edward would see
things
from the
this sort of
uncle the
from a place of innocence
um and
not knowing
exactly what things
meant or were
and and also that that look of
a
a pure
innocent
child when they experienced something
for the first time
um
those those were the
the two main ingredients that i
thought would
serve the character
and with
captain jack
again the cartoons
you know the
pepe le pew it was it was a
um
it's like it's like making a soup
you know it's ingredients it's just
ingredients
um
there's some le pew
in there there's some keith richards in
there
um
there's a bit of a
you know i figured this is a guy who's
been on the sea
for the majority of his life quite
possibly his brains may have been
scrambled a bit by the sun
and also i thought that he'd been on the
sea for so long that he had his sea legs
but when he got on land he just didn't
have his land legs so he could never
quite
stand still
how did the film ultimately turn out in
your view
i didn't see it
but uh i
believe that the film
well i mean the film did
pretty well apparently and uh
and they wanted to keep going uh making
uh making more and i was
fine to do that uh
as uh it was
it there's great freedom in
in
being able to
it's not like you become that person but
if if you know that character
to the degree that i did because
he was not what the writers wrote
so they really
weren't able to write for him
so once you know a character better than
the writers
that's when you
um
you have to uh be true to the character
and add your words at the rewrites um
i was
[Music]
yeah i know i i believed in the
character wholeheartedly and
the uh
initially the
disney
folks were
somewhat upset
now you mentioned that the film was to
your understanding a great success how
did your life change after the first
pirates of the caribbean movie came out
um
though i'd been around for many years
already and
[Music]
people people knew who i was and
all that
um
after pirates
one came out
there was a a completely different it
was a completely different uh
way of life was was was being sort of
you know
my family and i were being plunged into
that is to say you know
at our house in los angeles you would
have
you would have people trying to climb
the gates
to get into
[Music]
sea captain jack
um you would you would have people
trying to
bust in the gates
dressed as captain jack sparrow you
would ha
and
follow you or follow you and your family
so that was that was the moment when
um
there was no
other way
but to uh we had to hire more security
guards and i was certainly worried for
my kids
um safety
and so then we that's when the
instead of just the one guy
there were you know they were started
there became several security people
because i
wanted to make sure that my kids were
safe when they went to school or when
they went to disneyland or when they
went to
the mall or whatever
um
so yes more security and you know then
just getting followed
you know by hordes of paparazzi and
things like that it's it's it's uh
i've had worse jobs certainly i can't
complain about it
but um
yeah uh
after a while you realize that
anonymity
uh has left the building
a long time ago you know the anonymity's
gone
um
and that's it that's an odd thing to
deal with
um
when you just
i mean you can't just drive down to the
diner and get a cup of coffee or
something it's not uh
possible it it turns into something else
all together
so it's
you know
it's acceptance and of course there's a
bit of sacrifice
uh involved i i i can't complain
about the uh
work that i've been given
i can't complain about any of that
i have no right to
but
it does make you have to think very
creatively
with
when you've got little kids about how to
take them to the park
or you know to the swings or to this or
that or movie or you know
it becomes uh it becomes a strategic
mission
and and and that's what happened after
pirates
now you mentioned your family who did
your family consist of at that time
vanessa
um parody the mother of my children
um who we were together for
14 15 years
[Music]
myself uh our daughter lily rose and
our boy jack
now you mentioned hiring more security
did you already have a security team at
the time that pirates of the caribbean
came out
i've had i
yes
because there have been
there have been more films prior to that
a number of films prior to that so
i was
i was
recognized i was known so
if you wanted to attempt to have any
experience that might be normal
you sort of had to have somebody around
to
get you out of a squirrely situation
should it arise
so i had security
prior to that
for
who would travel with myself and my
family
but not like you know when i was at work
i back then i didn't
have security
work so much
not before pirates pirates was really
the uh
that was the thing that
everything um
it all turned around it all just went
went uh
weird
so how did your security team change
after pirates of the caribbean came out
well like i said with anything it had
become more strategic
and you had to have more guys
or gals
because
um because if if vanessa if vanessa for
example she worked in france quite a lot
and if she was in france
um
and
i was in l.a with the kitties
then
um
and working
security would
security would basically pick my kids up
at school or whatever and bring them
home
so that became the routine driving them
to school
bringing them home
um
so so yeah and then if i went somewhere
so
it just
the security guards
kind of multiplied
because you needed to
protect your street your house
your kids
endless
so after pirates of the caribbean who
has been on your security team
jerry judge was was with me
for
oh boy over 20 years
um
jerry judge
is
we've mentioned it before he um
uh it was a year or two ago he um
he jerry would go on film sets with me
he would he would do reconnaissance
missions you know that is to say he
would go to a country before we would go
there
make sure all the hotel rooms were all
taken care of and such
or when i went on tour with
say the hollywood vampires
which is a
band that i've played with
he would come on the road
with me with another security
guard
uh so there was jerry judge there was
malcolm connolly who's been with me for
20 years or more
um
leonard damien sean pett
um
travis
mcgivern
um
mark gibbs i mean
there are a few
are all of these uh security personnel
still with you today
jerry has gone on
to uh
somewhere else he's
jerry maid
jerry passed away
from cancer so jerry jerry made his exit
[Music]
but the majority of the no
i believe all of those fellows are still
with me yes
when did mr judge pass away
[Music]
i
believe it was
two
two years ago
roughly
maybe a little less than two years ago
um now i'd like to go through a couple
of the names that you just mentioned um
what is malcolm conley's purview in in
the realm of your security team
what is his role
exactly yes um
well
uh
now that
jerry is um
jerry and malcolm had worked together
for a very long time
so i've met malcolm through jerry
after after jerry's passing
malcolm obviously
took over
um
for jerry
and so he would
he would he took on
extra
responsibilities
he would have to
make sure that there was someone on the
ground
wherever we were going
that had done their
their uh
um
recon
you know the reconnaissance and to make
sure that uh um everything was set up by
the time we got there and that it would
be a straight shot into the hotel
without a gaggle of paparazzi
um
you know you didn't have to walk through
50 screaming
hollering
photographers
so you know you going through a garage
door
through a slippery kitchen and
you were then you were taken to your
room
where you stayed
when did uh when did malcolm conley join
your team
malcolm had
[Music]
joined mean jerry brought him on so
malcolm has been with me for over 20
years
uh now
and
in those 20 years how often have you
physically been present with malcolm
with malcolm
yes endless countless
all over the world
um all over the world
everywhere
los
angeles japan
um
serbia
you know films tour
um malcolm was my uh
he you know he he
when we were on the vampires tour in
europe throughout europe and malcolm was
on the bus with me we we lived on the
bus together basically
how often is malcolm in la with you
it depends if if there's a
or if there was a a
larger premiere you know
where um
you know where it had to be worked out
so that it didn't turn into
a chaotic
uh
and or dangerous event because sometimes
there are
between you and the people there are
these barriers
and
sometimes the professional
photographers or the professional
autograph people
will surge forward
and in the front rows of these behind
these berries you have
you have
little kids and
older women and older men and
so when the professionals would surge
forward these people would start getting
kind of crushed against the
this
metal
deterrent and
um
that that that was the that was the most
uh
worrisome thing
when when when when you're at a premiere
and
there are
thousands and thousands of people there
and
i've always called it running the
gauntlet essentially what it is is
that people are there
to
um
to say hi and to support
the film or the cast or whatever so i
um i've always
gone out and and signed for those people
i've always gone
out and signed for
all or as many as
i possibly could i mean to the point
sometimes jerry judge would literally
pick me up off the ground to make me
stop signing
take me away um
um
so
yeah uh
it was uh
those those those kind of things again
you don't you don't really get used to
that you know
so
i forget what the original part of your
question was i
got lost in the gauntlet i'll move on
what uh what about sean bett how long is
you want to go ahead and make it take a
break now would that be okay perhaps
that's fine let's go why don't we go
ahead and do that ladies and gentlemen
we'll go ahead and take our afternoon
break please do uh we'll take 15 minutes
do not discuss
uh the case and you know any outside
research okay thank you
stay there for a minute thank you
all right sir just a reminder since
you're on the witness stand now you
cannot discuss your testimony with
anybody to include your attorneys okay
all right and let's come back
i guess we can come back at 3 35 is that
okay for everybody okay we'll take
reasons thank you
all right we're ready for the jury yes
so
so
all right
okay
have a seat sir all right your next
question
uh mr depp i'd like to just briefly go
through the security personnel that you
just listed out before we took a break
um
how long has leonard damien be been with
you
[Music]
my
my kids are now 20
23 leonard's
leonard damian's been with me i believe
roughly the same time as mr bat
somewhere in the neighborhood of
16
17 years i
i yeah i can't be precise but they were
very young
my children were very young when when
they uh
joined the team which was really after
pirates was released in 2003
the first
now you mentioned your children is
what is
mr damian's role with respect to your
children's security excuse me
you mentioned your children with respect
to leonard damien is his role in
connection with your children's security
uh
yes
very much so leonard um
leonard is leonard damien
and um
and sean bet for for
quite a while
were both um
sort of assigned
as it were to to my kids um
taking them to school picking them up
from school if if
vanessa and i were unable to do it
or even if we were there we would drive
with them
to take the kids to school um
and
over the the years obviously
your your children uh
my children have taken
quite a shine to to to them
and they've become like um
another set of
parents in a way
and how long has travis mcgivern been
with you
travis i believe a little bit
less than that i believe
i i couldn't i couldn't
really speculate
it's a little less maybe it's
13 years
i don't know
now you mentioned that you had to bring
on additional security after pirates of
the caribbean
um
how has the fame associated with that
that franchise affected your your
personal relationships
[Music]
um
again
i would never
complain
about the
the repercussions let's say or
yeah the repercussions of
the success of
that film
um
but of course
as i said
there are sacrifices that
one
one has to make
um
sacrifices that you're
you're not nearly ready for
um
just simply when
when you check into a
when you go to a town or you
go on a press tour or something and
you're staying in a hotel
people stay in hotels all the time i
stay
i stay
in the hotel i it's
it's we've found that it's just a lot
easier
if i stay put in a hotel and
um
not
kind of
again especially if it's with the kids
or something
i don't want them to i i've never wanted
them to see me as
as a novelty i just wanted to be dad
you know
um
now
they're well aware of uh
a lot and they're well aware of pretty
much everything
um
but no you you you know you
when you get when you get recognized
uh wherever you go
um
the the basic the basic truth is it's
pretty simple
people
are generally
kind and curious
um and if
if you've if they've grown up
with you
in their living room
um from a television series or from
various films that that they've seen
um
there's there's nothing menacing about
being recognized as sometimes they can
be
sometimes people can get
go
get weird and
but but uh
um
we've
found
that it's it's just uh
it's it's better all around if
if i
stay in my hotel room and
and don't go out
to too many restaurants or anything
because
it
generally causes a bit of a hubbub
if you go to a restaurant someone calls
the paparazzi and
you go in for a meal and you come out
and there's 30 guys out there it's uh
it can be
a little overwhelming
it's not it's not something i think i
said it before it's it's not something
that i that that
it's not something that i've ever gotten
used to and it's something that i hope
never get used to
because
i don't think of myself in those terms
i used to be
um
i used to be johnny
if if that makes sense
i used to be johnny
and then my
name full name which i i i
honestly find still it's difficult if i
it's uncomfortable to say my own
name
because i when i say it
i hear the commodity i hear the product
so
i just
i went from johnny
to
johnny depp
and
um and then that name
um
with that name johnny depp and
some image was cultivated
um
certainly not by
me but but
the the
media
um
especially in those days they must label
you
they have to give you
a label
um
and
labels one of the things that i've
fought
vigorously with regard to my work
i i
i never wanted to be
the poster boy
i never wanted to be the uh
i don't have
you know i'm not built with that kind of
hubris i don't
i don't have that kind of uh
uh
confidence i i can do
virtually anything
playing a character
i can become the
character in my
work
um and that character
may be able to we may be able to spit
out a hundred words a minute
but
me myself johnny
i uh
cannot
so they're there in lies the difference
you know
mr depp other than acting what other
artistic pursuits do you have that
may be a little less known to the
general public
well i've remained a
musician
a musician um
i started playing the guitar when i was
12 years old
and
that saved my life
because
i locked myself into a in my bedroom
at the age of 12
listening to
you know records
moving the needle back and then
learning that piece and then
learning it again so
so much so
i mean that i i i i don't remember uh
i i have no memory of going through
puberty i i i uh
i was just playing the guitar i was just
i was obsessed with uh my guitar
any other artistic pursuits
um
i
yeah i mean i've always
drawn since i was very small this is
very little
um
and always enjoyed drawing and then
began to paint um and so
there
started
learning about painting and
trying to um
it
i suppose different ways
of of expressing oneself
different ways to
different ways to
release
the things that are
living in
in your head
whether they be
beautiful memories whether they be
horrific memories whether they be
um
i i
i i have a
um
i need to
create it's it's a need
it's a
of course i want to create as well but i
i actually need
to create because i need to
summon
whatever
whatever it is that i need to summon to
whether then whether that's within a
film
or a
painting or
a guitar note
um
all of those things should come from a
place
of
an organic place a place of truth
because if they don't
well then you're just
lying aren't you i i
every
bit of truth
a person doesn't have to say anything on
film
what's important is what's behind the
eyes
and if they do say something what's
important is not necessarily the words
that they say it's very easy to say i
love you
but
what brings it
into the
realm of truth is
what's underneath it what's not being
said the subtext
if you will
so
um
any
artistic or creative
venture any film any thing that i do
that's um that's where i'm coming from
that's that's my approach
mr duff you mentioned words and i think
the jury has already seen some words
that you've written in text messages
can you please tell the jury a little
bit about how you write
certainly i am
when i was young when i was about 12
years old my my elder brother
danny um
walked into my room and
ripped the peter frampton record off my
record player
threw it across the room
and said you got to stop listening to
this stuff and he put this record on
and
it started
and i'd never heard anything like it was
called
astral weeks by van morrison
so i'm a kid you know 12 years old so
my brother turned me on to van morris
and then he turned me on to soundtracks
like clockwork orange or um um last
tango in paris
um he turned me on to books by jack
kerouac he turned me onto books by
ginsburg
um
philip k dick i mean
salinger i mean the whole
james joyce the hemingway the whole
thing so
um
so i became very interested in
the vocabulary and and the
the
the unique
voices
of these writers
um
and then i started reading people like
tom robbins
and hunter s thompson
and then ended up becoming very close
friends with with um with hunter
thompson
for the last
10 12 years of his life and uh
hunters
riding of course
because of the amount i spent
of time i spent with him
it has influenced my writing
greatly
hunter was
known for
inventing a thing called gonzo
journalism which is
it's it's
it's uh the author putting himself in
the situation
as opposed to writing it from the
author's point of view he writes it
with him in it
and
there are great
[Music]
embellishments and
embellishments are great
sort of
ways that he would
twist things
and um express
um
his his his his feelings um
and
so he he became a huge hero of course
to me and a great friend
i uh
in my texts and in my emails or
sometimes just even in my writing
you do
[Music]
you take
you
you take the subject and you
um
try to express it in your own vernacular
and and in that
um
as
for example with the text messages that
i apologize that everyone's had to uh
experience
i am ashamed of uh
of some of the references
made i'm
embarrassed
that at the time
the heat
of the moment
the heat of
the pain
um that i was feeling
um
went to
[Music]
went to dark places
there is no
if you're riding
there is no
set place that you have to
stay in you can travel
and sometimes
pain
be
has to be dealt with
with humor
and
sometimes
dark very dark humor
um i
i grew up watching monty python
you know
so yes it can tend to get into
dark
humor
it can
tend to get uh
um
words are used that
for emphasis
um
[Music]
and words are used to express
what what you're feeling at the time
and um
it's just like growing up
you
learn
from those
mistakes
you learn from those
things and um
you move forward
you know
um
and
that that's how you
that's how you start to understand
your own vernacular
and what's important
you know what's
necessary what's not necessary
um
i tend to be quite expressive in my
writing
and
after um
after the
after the
unfortunate
words of
misheard
um
[Music]
made their way into my
heart
and my head
those are those are
two very opposing
things so you're you're trying to
you you're trying to find the best way
to express something to a friend
sometimes you're exaggerating
you know
something that you've done
just to make it sound just to make him
understand that
uh uh you know i'm on i'm on planet
question mark here
i don't know what's going on and i
but i know i'm in this
situation and i know that
it cannot continue
mr dubsta the jury's heard quite a bit
from miss herdside about your drug and
alcohol use
but i'm sure they'd like to hear from
you so could you please just tell them
about your history of substance use
certainly
um
again this this goes back to when i was
a
young boy
um
excuse me um
at about the age of i don't know
four or five years old i i can
remember
vividly my
my mom
[Music]
telling me to go get her nerve pills you
know
um
out of her purse that was hanging on the
back of the door
so i'd go get the nerve pills and i'd
bring her the nerve pill
to take it
and um
you know after a few years you start to
notice
well you start to think about nerve
pills
nerve pills
and then she seemed to calm down after
she took those
nerve pills
so
when i was 11 years old
um
i wanted to calm down
and i didn't know how to
so i
i bring my mom her nerve pill
i would walk away
and i would
take one myself
um
to escape
caring
so much feeling
so much
to escape
the
[Music]
the chaotic
um
nature of what
what we were living
through
um
so that that was the beginning
when i
realized that nerve pills
calmed the nerves
um
pretty young age to do that i
can't
say that i'm proud of admitting to that
but but i i have to say that i knew
not
what else to do i knew nothing else
that i could do
um
so
as we were all growing up
there was always those kids who would
say let's party
let's go party i want to party
i've never used
the word party in my life
i've never
i've never taken
any substance
uh for a party
i have taken these substances over the
years
on and off
um
to numb to numb
myself
of
of uh
of the
the ghosts the wraiths that
were still with me and um
from from from my youth
so um
i needed yeah i
they were everything
it was essentially it was just
self-medication
um
one of those get me out of here
moments and you know where you want to
escape
from is your own brain your own head
how often have you used substances
throughout your life
um
having started with
my mother's nerve pills at 11.
of course the the you know
that's around the age that
you're introduced to
marijuana
um
you're introduced to
and also depending on
where you're living and who you're
um associating with and who's around the
neighborhood
um
i
know i wasn't shy to
try
a substance
for
to see if the effect of it would
maybe even
take a bit more of the edge off
so i i started
at 11
and
i mean
i even mentioned this in an
interview and tv guide
if anyone remembers tv guide
um in 1989
where i was asked by the journalist
why
i believed that
kids who were watching the show
tony one jump street about police
officers in school
under as undercover
undercover cops but
but as students
um i was asked why
people why these
kids or whoever should
should believe
me or trust me or listen to me and i
said look i i
i
could
because i've experienced it and i can
tell them
that there is
no future in it that there's
nothing but a a a kind of an
uh postponing of the inevitable
that one day you're going to have to
face those feelings one day you will
meet
those
let's call them
demons
from your youth
um so i i was i was i was straight up
open and honest
at that time in in a very
i mean tv guide was
it was right at the register when you
checked out at the grocery store it was
like the most popular thing in and it
was a very straight magazine a little
magazine
but i i i told them i'd pretty much done
all the drugs that i was aware of by the
time i was 15 years old
and which is true
now
that doesn't mean to say that i
continued
into that you know forest of of uh
possibilities
with regard to substances
um
i i wasn't
um
dropping ass at every five minutes i
wasn't
i i there were many years that i
didn't touch it
substance and no drugs there were many
years that i
didn't have a drink um
so it's
as i said
it's never been for
the sort of party effect it's been for
trying to
numb the things inside that have
that that that plague that can plague
plague someone's uh
who's who's experienced trauma
um
but
the the
characterization
um
of
the characterization of
my
substance
quote-unquote substance abuse
that's been delivered by
ms heard is is
is is
is grossly
embellished
um
[Music]
and i'm sorry to say but
a lot of it is
it's just plainly false
i think that
it was easy
it wasn't easy
i think it was an easy target
for her
to hit because once you've trusted
somebody
for a certain amount of years and you've
told them
all the secrets of your life
that information then of course can be
used
against you especially if it's taken to
a point that is teetering on
impossible uh
and tears over impossible in fact at
times
it's so i
i
am not
some
maniac who needs
um
to be high or loaded all the time i
in fact
in australia from before australia and
in australia
i had been um
off of alcohol
for i believe it was about 18 months
mr jeff you've mentioned some periods of
sobriety throughout your life how many
would you estimate
you've had
uh
quite a number you know
on on various films you see
um guess maybe by example if if anyone's
well if you're familiar with hunter
thompson's book fear and loathing in las
vegas
which i i was uh lucky enough to make uh
into a film and with terry gilliam
the
the film calls for
myself and my attorney
to be
absolutely blotto out of our heads
constantly
throughout the film
and most people just assumed that
well they just got wasted and they
filmed them
there would have been no way to you
couldn't act that you couldn't i mean
you couldn't make that film with two
actors who were loaded
there would be no way
um
and then to the other extreme donnie
brasco
a film that i made about
an fbi agent
i i had to uh
i had to go and go into a training
regime where i
i had to eat five meals a day drink five
shakes a day you know these protein
shakes per day
um work out three to four hours a day
because i had to gain 20 to 30 pounds of
muscle
uh
um
there was certainly
no abuse of um
substances
then
i
there's
been no abusive substances
on film sets there have been
no
there's been no
there's been no moments
where
i would have been considered out of
control
never
in fact
it's not been mentioned that like i'm
sure they don't want to mention it but i
remember that because we
when i was
with missouri
and her friends and we were all drinking
wine
um
and i
smoking
marijuana
um
they would they used to tease me
because because of
what they said was a
ludicrous tolerance
because i
because i never appeared
bloated or high or
any of that i i um
even if i even if i felt a little
spinny
i know
no one would have ever known you know
mr deb is there any substance that
you've ever been addicted to
yes and what is that
um
roxy codone
or roxy cotton
which is um
it's an opiate
it's um
i think i think
oxycodone has
the opiate and then
some
pain like a paracetamol or something
and then the roxies are just the
opiate as far as i uh remember and um
when i was i was working on pirates four
and uh
there there was a scene in which i had
to um
grab this
large gold and
gold
and red you know
stately
guilt
chair pick it up and
throw it chuck it out this
big giant window
and so
i did it
and
as i swung around to throw the throw the
chair out the window
um
i felt this immediate
electricity from
from the bottom of my spine
down to
down my left leg um
and it was like an electricity that
burned it
so
i had
obviously done it was sciatica so i
obviously pinched
something done something so i went to
[Music]
i saw a chiropractor or a teenager or
whatever i saw chiropractors and and
to no avail
then i saw a doctor and
and the only
pain medication that she
recommended and prescribed to me was a
roxycodone
um
and uh
there was a part of me that was a little
bit
worried
just in a sense that
i i know
um i
witnessed uh
friends and
people over the years who have um
[Music]
who've had problems with uh
heroin you know um and
i i didn't want to get bit by that snake
and
i started taking the
roxies and
i was bit by the snake
and then before you know it
um that
that monkey is on your back to stay
and it's not like you take those
pills to get high
you you take them to
[Music]
once once once the addiction has grabbed
hold of you
you
you're not taking those pills to get
high you're taking those pills
to get
well
or to
get better
because if
you're without the pill
your body will start to go into
various uh
you'll
withdrawals and um
so i was i was on the
rocks roxy's for
a number of years uh
four or five years i think maybe more i
don't know but
um
the key was that i
i
if you take two
you will be
um what they call on the not you will be
that you'll you'll just drop into sleep
um
[Music]
so
um
yes i
i didn't like being dependent
on on these on these pills i didn't like
being dependent on
on
a
on a drug
that would
you take
only so you wouldn't get
withdrawals
that's what it becomes
it's like a junkie
the reason why
so many
uh well now there's a huge fentanyl
problem but
the reason why junkies generally why
they end up overdosing is because
they're looking for the first high
again
and you
you don't get that
you don't get your first high again
so
what do you do
you up the stakes and you
put more you take more
and and that's
what makes
them
that's what makes things go dark for
them
because
they overestimated
the amount that they
that their body could tolerate and they
go
blue and they die
so
um
yeah didn't want that
mr depp do you have an estimate as to
what year you started taking the the
opiates that you just described
um when uh 2000 or excuse me uh it was
pirates
bless you
four i believe
pirates four no was pirates four rob
marshall directed it
um
i don't know what year that was
maybe
i actually don't i have no idea what
year that was
was it before you were in a relationship
with miss heard
yes
i believe so
and you didn't
detox and you detoxed from those opiates
during your relationship with ms hurt is
that right
yes
yeah so of course yes so they must have
yeah they did come around
prior to my meeting miss heard
after you detox from the opiates have
you ever taken any opiates ever again
no i
can't that's a
no
once you've been bit
you'll be bit again
so no i
with any
i mean even with
my
finger
uh
i i think that
it was like motrin 800
you know but no opiates no i have not
taken an opiate since and i won't
un unless i
plan on
going through the
the hell of
the pure
horror of
detoxing
of coming off those drugs
now
mr depp i'd like to now turn to your
relationship with miss heard
um can you please tell the jury how you
met miss heard
um
2 000
in around 2008 uh
hunter
thompson and i were
going through some of his manuscripts uh
of his books
that have been published and then
i
i found this
manuscript in one of his boxes
and it was called the rum diary
and i had heard about it and i knew it
was what they called his long-lost
novel in fact the only novel he ever
wrote
um
and i showed it to him and
hunter was hunter was shocked my god
that's where it is you know
and uh
so he said read me some so i started
reading
this to him and he said
this is a movie you know we we must
produce this together and you know he
got all excited about the
idea of doing that so we went right into
it
and we started to
um set up meetings to
to get to to get money
financing to develop the project
and
we finally ended up getting
the money to develop the project and to
make the film
hunter
um
from his own
dilemmas in his
in his life
committed suicide
um
and uh
but i
having had long long talks with him i
knew every
angle
of the book but i knew every angle of
the film that he wanted which was going
to be a bit different than the book
and
bruce robinson
who was a great writer director directed
a film called with nail and i and how to
get ahead in advertising
was the one director that hunter and i
talked about and so i
i went to bruce who was a friend of mine
and i
ripped him out of retirement because he
never wanted to direct another film
again
i pulled him out of retirement after 27
years and he agreed to write the
screenplay
and direct the film and
we proceeded uh during the auditioning
process
um
bruce bruce was
[Music]
before that hunter had very specific
ideas of what these characters
should be
um
bruce had been auditioning
um
girls or women from for the role of
chennault in the film
and
there were the there were this sort of
the starlets that were
up and coming and
or there were some that were well known
and
um
things of that nature
but
you know one of the things that hunter
was very against was stunt casting that
is to say
put a bunch of very famous people in a
movie and we'll let them go
and and then
hope for the money in the in the end
so
bruce had asked me he said he'd been
auditioning
uh this this one particular actress
named amber heard
he said that he'd auditioned her five
times
and he was um
he wasn't sure about her
capabilities
um as an actress
with regard to
the film
and the character and what
and taking direction and
that sort of thing so he asked me if i
would
read with her
for the
for the film and i'd met
already met a number of actresses and
things
and and so what i said to mr robinson is
i said bruce i i don't if you've if
you've auditioned her five times
you've seen
the best and the worst i suppose
so me
putting
her
this this girl in an uncomfortable
situation
you know saying hey all right let's read
this
i
i think is i think it's i think it's a
far better idea that
we just meet
so that i can
see how she behaves
see how she reacts
because that's really all it is
reaction
behavior
and you don't have to push anything else
you know
um
so i'm
they made an appointment
uh she she came to my office
i took one look at her and i thought
yeah
that's
that's
that's the chanult that hunter wants
that's the one
i just i thought yeah she could
definitely kill me
that's uh that's what hunter wants
and so we spoke
and she was
sweet as pie pleasant
again you know
intelligent
literate
very good taste
um
and i felt
like
if she
what i felt and what i told bruce was
look
when you put someone in a situation that
that that they're obviously going to be
feel under pressure
um
it's not the best way to to really
to really know what they're capable of
and
[Music]
i
made suggestions such as
um and which i ended up making to ms
heard
i made suggestions of films that might
give her
some insight into what what we were
looking for in terms of the film
which is to say i gave her films like to
have and have not um
things that need to be
because
i wanted to
there was something very important that
she i thought felt she needed to know
about
stillness as opposed to
you know
going
abroad or
or or
taking
acting a little too much
so i felt like i could
i felt like i could be a bit of a
traffic cop in that sense so that
because if we if we could connect
then
it would it could work as long as there
was truth in her eyes and as long as
there was truth coming out of her
uh
dialogue
you know then it's all in the editing
so i i i
felt that i could help her with that
idea of stillness um
and so that's where that's when i first
met miss heard
how would you describe your interactions
with miss heard when you worked together
on the rum diary
um
initially you know mostly very very
very few interactions
um
i remember there was a time i wasn't
working that day
but i was producing you know one of the
producers of the film and um
it was a scene from the book
that
that was it was a it was a it was a
scene where
ms heard's character was in a nightclub
and
were amongst
um the locals
and she's very drunk and everybody's
very drunk and
she ends up
dancing
with a few of the local like one of the
local guys and stuff and then
the other local guys start to sort of
close in on her
in the book and in the screenplay as it
was written
there was a
she there was a required
requirement for nudity
um
for the part and uh
i was on set the day that they were
shooting that
and
as i was watching
the crowd coming in on her i realized
you know what because i would check on
ms heard and say are you all right are
you sure you're okay because this is you
know she was like no no i'm fine fine
but i realized that with the crowd
surging in towards her
that
we didn't have to do we wouldn't have to
do the nudity
because if she
if she took her shirt off and she had
a red bra
on
and a skirt
then
if she had a red bra in her hand
when the crowd surged in on her all she
had to do
was lift the red bra
up out of the crowd
and
[Music]
there's no nudity but
it's certainly implied
because then she disappears for the
character disappears for a few days and
um
and she's quite a wreck when she comes
back because
bad things have happened to her
so i i remember
telling miss her hey you don't
you don't have to uh
you don't have to take your clothes off
you don't have to take your top off you
don't have to everything's cool
um
and she was appreciative
um
and uh but but other than that we didn't
really
have much interaction
until um
until there was a
um a scene where i i was i'm taking a
shower and then she comes into the
room and she walks
opens the shower and we kiss
and uh
that moment was um
it was um
yeah it it it was a it was
it felt like something
um
it felt like something that i shouldn't
be feeling because she
had
her wife um and
even though it was a scene and and she
had a wife and and i had
vanessa and
kitties and
um
yeah
when would you say your romantic
relationship with miss heart actually
began if if not in that moment
well
i think there was something in the kiss
in the shower
that was very
real
so that day after
work
mr
had come to my trailer
and i was uh
i was i was
i was just sitting there listening to
actually old blues stuff
and um
we
had a glass of wine and
um
and
and
we kissed
um
and at that point we were the my trailer
was the only trailer in the parking lot
um
she had a mind to stay
in the trailer there
for a while with me and i uh
didn't think that was a very good idea
on any level especially since there were
about nine teamsters waiting to move the
trailer
um then that was
that
on
till
until whenever the uh
we did the first day of the press junket
for the rum diary in los angeles
uh two years later
and
she had she had
broken up i believe with her wife and
my uh
for lack of a
well my wife
weren't married married but she was of
course my wife vanessa
um
we have had uh
some
not so great
um situations
you know um
she wanted she needed she needed
she was stuck in america
she wanted to go back to france she
wanted to have her life back
she's a no she's a well-known singer
there she
um and that's
not long after right around then is when
miss heard and i
started to uh
see each other
here and there occasionally
between the end of
the filming of the rum diary and the the
press junket did you and miss herd
communicate at any time in between
i don't remember i remember
that there was a there was a white dress
that she was really she really was
infatuated with that she really loved
this dress that she wore in the film
and
so i i went to calling out with the
costume designer and to
bruce and i said
do you think we can snag this
this white dress
and send it to
to amber you know after she'd rap
because she loved the she loved the
thing
i remember talking to i think
then
but
briefly
briefly
what did you like about miss heard when
you first
started your romantic relationship
she's she seemed to be
she seemed to be the
um
she seemed to be the perfect
partner
in a sense
in my head for me because she
as i said she
she was she seemed to be very
knowledgeable about
old obscure blues music that i listened
to and really
um
she
was literate she was
sweet
funny
nice all those things you know
and and and she was
and
from the beginning of our relationship
at that time
for a good year year and a half um
she was
she was wonderful
and and then things just
started to
change or
things started to reveal themselves
that's i think is a better way to put it
you mentioned earlier in your testimony
that miss heard would would take off
your boots when you would get home from
work
what other types of
behaviors did you observe and misheard
early in the relationship
um
little things that you would kind of it
would just you'd question in in the back
of your mind you know if
if
if
she wanted to go to bed
until
i i i can't sleep you know right now
and rather than go and just lay in a bed
and stare at the ceiling
i would say
uh you know i'll just watch i'll be out
here watching tv or hanging out and and
that was just not acceptable
it's not acceptable
it would uh it would steer up
some some rather
unusual um
reactions
from her i i i didn't understand why i
as a 50 some year old
man
was not allowed to go to sleep when i
wanted to
uh as opposed to when she wanted to it
started out with little things like that
and again they just
they eventually they just
i suppose like anything
if they're allowed to continue then they
then they are allowed to
grow they're allowed to blossom
into whatever they're going to
become what were you and miss heard's
nicknames for each other
um
i called her slim
why is that i called her slim
um because of the the film that i had
given her to watch about in terms of
stillness was
lauren bacall and humphrey bogart
and
i called her slim and she called me
steve which was
lauren mccall's and humphrey bogart's
nickname
uh nicknames for each other in the in
the film that was their names in the
film
um and it you know it wasn't also wasn't
lost on me
the fact that uh
there was an age difference and that uh
um
my god when when when when humphrey
bogart and lauren mccall
that's when they met on that film he was
45 years old and she was 19.
um
and they stayed together until bogart
passed away
so
yeah the the the the
there was a kind of a
joke not joke but just
uh
yeah
i acknowledged the
the fact that i was the old craggy bogey
and she was this
um
beautiful
um
creature just this
stunning creature
when did you first meet miss hurt's
parents
i first met miss heard's parents when
uh they they had come out to los angeles
i believe and uh yeah
and and uh
i feel i feel like that i met them i
think they came to
my place to me
to my studio
and um
they were two completely
opposite ends of the end of the spectrum
people page
um
was
she was an angel
she was an angel
and
and
i loved her very much i i i loved her
instantly
and we had a very good relationship
her father
david was the opposite end of that he
was this
outrageous kind of
almost like a cartoon cowboy you know
and he was
the initial thought i mean my initial
kind of definition
for david would have been
rascally like a rascal you know
um
but i
i
i
i loved i mean i grew to love them both
very much uh as well as her
uh
her sister whitney
and um
yes it felt like i had been welcomed
into some sort of
family
i had been accepted into this
this family and um
those relationships stayed
solid
until just a bit after
we'd
separated
how often did you spend time with miss
herd's parents during your relationship
with miss heard
quite a lot
whether we
i used to have a boat
um
and we would go
we would take her parents or family and
we'd
go
sail the boat and um
you know
drop anchor at the island and um
we would spend a week two weeks whatever
on the boat on the island
also
they would come to los angeles quite a
bit we also would go to austin here and
there
to see them visit them
every year we would uh
on their anniversary
um
i had a friend of mine who had a
restaurant in austin very like a very
good restaurant in austin
and uh i'd i'd call him up and
basically basically set it up so that
every
year on their anniversary they could
just go there
and
and um
they'd be taken care of and there would
be no bill so they could just celebrate
and
i think one of the things we did was
yes
we would try to order them car so that
uh
they could drink
um
well i i i i was very fond of them very
fond of them
now you mentioned miss heard's sister
whitney when did you first meet whitney
i don't remember exactly when i met
whitney the first time but i i've
but i felt when i when i first met
whitney
there was something in
there was something in what i saw
of whitney that was
less
much less confident than
amber
um
much more
um
revealing of
insecurities
um
uh
objection your honor just foundation
what he saw in whitney i think if you
can answer the question
you want to ask the question again
we can move on okay that's fine
um
how would you describe your relationship
with whitney
great i mean fantastic
she was
i called her sis
i loved her you know i felt
i had always felt something
i'd always felt like whitney had missed
out on something
same objection
we can move on okay
where was whitney living when you first
when you and miss heard first started
your relationship
she was living with her
then boyfriend sean kraszewski
was this in the same
where was ms heard living when you first
started your relationship
uh miss former miss mister had informed
me that she just moved
to a new place on
orange avenue
what city is that in los angeles sorry
yeah and
was a whitney also living in los angeles
whitney was living in los angeles yes
whether with sean
kraszyski and
so how often would you see whitney um
when you and miss heard were in a
relationship oh a lot
whitney would
whitney would come over all the time
with her boyfriend for
dinners and
such uh
ms hurt always liked having um
people over you know for dinner
parties and
socially shows you know social kind of
events that are at her at her
place
have you ever done any drugs with uh
whitney
[Music]
yes
how often would you do that
with whitney
yes with whitney
maybe two two three times maybe twice
three times
did there come a time when whitney moved
into
um the penthouses that you owned at the
eastern columbia building
yes and and when was that
i don't remember exactly when it was but
i
i
do remember that it was after
uh
rocky
uh pennington
and
yes i believe josh drew was there
already as well
um
whitney
i can't remember why she
needed a place but she
needed a place that we gave her
penthouse 4
to live in
how long did she live there for
boy
on and off for
[Music]
i suppose a couple of years
and how much rent did you charge her
uh
[Music]
nothing
[Music]
now you said you did drugs a couple
times with with whitney what what drugs
were you doing with whitney
whitney and i had
done a
line or two of cocaine together
when did you start getting introduced to
miss heard's friends after you started
your relationship with her
almost immediately well in fact
immediately yeah
immediately
i was introduced to
[Music]
the whole gang you know
rocky
io
brittany eustace
whitney certainly um
who else
that this all comes to mind at the
moment
no you you mentioned rocky uh
who is that specifically raquel
pennington who was
necessarily a
good friend from
youth i suppose
and i think you mentioned brittany
eustis as well who was that
um
brittany eustis was uh
just one of the gals you know she was
one of the gals and uh
she was quite bubbly and funny and
um
real sweet girl southern southern girl
i haven't seen her
i i think i think that the i think that
something
went sideways between
britney users and the girls because she
suddenly just disappeared from the group
when was that
probably
we were probably uh
a year and a half or maybe two no
two two years into the relationship
three years maybe
and i believe you mentioned someone
named io who is that
um i owe
io till it write it was a
a friend of
miss herds
from new york city
who um
was
um
who who had identified as a
as a
was born a female
if that's the right terminology these
days
born of female but she was um
she
she had chosen
um
she
at a very young age she had decided that
she
was a
she was a male and she identified as a
male
um
and io seemed to be
again uh
she was
she was uh
very
intelligent very literate
um kind of a
go get them kind of activist type
and
she was writing a book
i remember
she was writing a book um io or he was
writing a book rather
and um
i i had a house on one of my
own sweets or one of the houses there
was empty
and it was in fact a house
that i'd set up to to write in and
when she she had no place
uh
to stay or
go whatever i i
i
called her over and i showed her the
house
you know
where the task was and
all the things and
so she
i said write your book
you know
write your book here so i so she she did
did io end up living in that house or
just working there
no no io ended up
no she she ended up
living in the house for
somewhere in the neighborhood of a year
i guess
somewhere about a year
and how much rent did you charge to io
nothing
and did there also come a time when um
rocky moved into the penthouses at the
eastern columbia building iraqi moved
into penthouse
two
and do you recall when that was
oh no penthouse one sorry
pandels one
that was that was
not long after
[Music]
ms hurd and i started to
begin to dress that place
up as our residence
so it wasn't very long after that at all
that uh
rocky and rocky came um
i had already
had my
friend isaac who who
you've met um isaac baruch painter he
had already
given him a
penthouse to
to stay in and
live in and
paint in because he had
he'd just come back from florida and
his mom had passed away and i think he
had about three dollars in his pocket so
i i gave him the pen house and
asked him if he had enough paint and
so he lived there
why did um rocky move into the
penthouses
projection foundation
i'll overrule foundation and hear say
the question potentially calls for your
second i don't i'll rule that but
[Music]
go ahead mr deb
um
why did
sorry what was it again
why did rocky end up moving into the
penthouses
um
she ended up moving into the penthouses
um
i don't recall i i believe it was
something to do with just not having
a a place
and
amber had asked if i
would be okay with you know
rocky moving in
and i said of course it's uh
the penthouse is empty
i i wasn't in the uh i wasn't going to
be renting them out
necessarily anyway you know
they were
for friends to come and stay
penthouse 4 in fact was initially
planned out for my sister christy to
have an escape from
her
3 000 grandchildren and
and the amount of work load that she had
taken on at the company
how long did miss pennington end up
staying in the penthouses
longer than isis
and how much rent did you charge to miss
pennington
nothing
did anyone live with miss pennington in
the penthouses
yes
her fiance or boyfriend and fiance josh
drew
and then at a certain point i learned
that there was
another female living there who i i
wasn't sure who that was i didn't know
who that was
it was it because it was a there were
there were two bedrooms
and so she had invited a friend to move
in
but i
i met that person very briefly
a while after they'd already been living
there
i had a good breaking point i think this
is a good stopping point that's fine all
right ladies and gentlemen it is five
o'clock so we'll go ahead and break for
the evening again did not discuss the
case with anybody and don't do any
outside research okay and we'll see you
in the morning at 10 a.m all right thank
you you're
your excuse for the day thank you
all right
and again sir since you're in the middle
of your testimony did not discuss your
testimony with anybody to include your
attorneys this evening okay all right
you can you can stand down if you'd like
okay thank you
all right is there any other matters for
this evening
sure sure
all right
do
you